buying and selling turnips is hands-down
the most efficient way of making bells
in Animal Crossing new horizons and know
that number you're seeing right now is
not a mirage did you know it's actually
possible to closely predict what your
prices will be each week in this video
I'll share all the secrets of buying and
selling turnips and animal crossing new
horizons and we're starting right now
[Music]
people of the internet retro reckons who
are here your guide to family-friendly
content in the world of video games we
stream over on Twitch every Monday and
Wednesday at 9 p.m. Eastern and the
stream you're watching right now is when
those nook boys were buying turnips on
my Island for a whopping 619 bells
I opened up my Island for a few hours so
folks can come by and sell their turnips
for huge profits to be honest with you
when I started playing New Horizons I
had no idea the prices could go that
high so today I'd like to share with you
five tips to maximize your turnip
profits if you're new here and enjoy
this video please consider subscribing
as it really helps to grow the channel
don't forget to hit that thumbs up
button before you go number one know
when and where to buy turnips after you
unlock nook's cranny turnips will be
sold every Sunday starting at 4 a.m. all
the way until noon
the trick is they're sold by a vendor
named Daisy Mae who spawns in a random
spot on your Island you should actually
get a letter from Daisy Mae once your
nooks crannies shop is open one Sunday
at 4 a.m. rolls around she'll appear on
your island she won't go into any of
your homes or buildings but will walk
around a bit and it's very easy to pass
her by she's behind a tree or another
building you want to make sure you clear
out your pockets before you talk to her
if you're planning to buy a lot of
turnips and let's be honest you should
definitely buy as many as you can so
long as you can spare the bells after
you locator talk to her and find out
what prices the turnips are selling for
they'll come in stacks of 10 and cost
between 90 and 110 Bells per
Poorna as long as you're able to follow
this guide it really shouldn't matter
what price they're selling for now some
guys will tell you not to buy them if
they're over a hundred but if you're
feeling apprehensive about buying
turnips even when they're a high price
don't worry the final tip in this video
will make sure you never lose any bells
and remember turnips must be sold the
same week they're purchased so that
means each Saturday evening is your
deadline to sell if any of your turnips
aren't sold by Sunday morning they'll
spoil and become completely worthless
unless you still need to catch a flier
ant which is really the only use of a
spoiled turnip number to store your
turnips so unlike most items in the game
turnips can't be placed in your house as
storage instead you'll need to find a
place to drop them really any room in
your house will do now some people have
a lot of furniture and prefer to store
the turnips outside instead you can
certainly drop them on the ground as
long as you aren't worried about someone
else on your Island having them from you
other players prefer to bury their
turnips which takes a little more time
because of the digging however it does
keep all the turnips from cluttering up
your Island you could even create a
special fenced off section just for
holding your turnips each week number
three check your prices daily Tommy and
Timmy will buy turnips any day of the
week except for Sunday you can sell
during their regular business hours of 8
a.m. to 10 p.m. the trick here is that
prices will change you'll have an
initial price when they open at 8:00
a.m. and then a new price at 12 p.m. I
strongly advise you not to time travel
when you have turnips you risk them
being spoiled and you'd lose all the
bells you put in so even if you miss a
price check at nook's cranny don't be
tricked into time traveling to check on
a miss price now the range for buying
turnips we mentioned is being between 90
and 110 bells for selling your turnips
I've heard of them going as low as nine
bells and as high as 660 bells in fact
here from the very beginning of this
video you saw on my Island they were
going for 619 Bell
so don't panic if your first couple of
days are lower than you'd hoped and that
leads us to number four identify your
pattern in animal crossing new horizons
your turn up selling prices will
actually follow one of four patterns
folks in the Animal Crossing community
refer to these as the small spike large
spike decreasing and fluctuating now
stay with me here because I promise
there's an easy way to do this with the
small spike pattern you'll be looking
for a decreasing trend followed by three
moderate increases in a row and by
moderate we mean between twenty and
forty bells if this happens you can
expect the next price change which would
be a fourth straight increase to be an
even bigger increase and that's when you
should sell the large spike is similar
to the small spike except it's the third
price jump you'll be watching but how do
you know if it's different from the
small spike as we mentioned before small
spikes usually have those three jumps
between twenty and forty bells if your
third jump is bigger than a forty Bell
jump chances are you have the large
spike and you should probably sell
confused yet wouldn't it be great if
there was a website out there to track
your price changes and let you know
which pattern you most likely have it
just so happens there are multiple sites
that do this
I actually prefer one called turnip
profit on this site you'll want to input
as much information as you can
even your turnip purchase price as
apparently it has some impact
behind-the-scenes on which pattern you
get I've been using the site for several
weeks now and have found it to be fairly
reliable and accurate as you input the
daily price changes turn a profit we'll
let you know which pattern is most
likely for the week it will even give
you a range of prices you can expect to
see I'll definitely be linking this went
down in the description below because
it's an incredibly valuable tool for
mastering the stock market now as for
the fluctuating trend it's pretty
self-explanatory it's mostly random
although the prices usually seem to
range between 40 and 200 bells the
decreasing pattern is by far the worst
your prices will start low and continue
down the entire week but wait didn't I
say early in the video I could guarantee
you won't
your bells that's where number five
comes in if all else fails visit a
friend
your biggest ace in the hole when it
comes to selling turnips is you can sell
them on another island it doesn't have
to be on your own island now even if you
don't have any friends who play Animal
Crossing there are multiple websites out
there dedicated to this there's the AC
turnip subreddit the turnip exchange
subreddit in a turnip exchange website
and many more I'll link those three down
in the description below
hey if all else fails you can always hit
me up on Twitch and check my turnip
prices for the week
I can't wait to hear from you guys how
much you're making with these tips so
let me know down in the comments below
and if you have any questions at all
I'll be happy to answer them that's
gonna be it for today's video I'll talk
to you again soon